we make way for the Hall of Famer Bret
Favre throughout the NFL season you can
hear Brett talking about the league
every week on Sirius XM NFL radio and he
hosts Sirius XM blitz every Tuesday at
noon eastern good morning Brett how are
you I'm good how about yourself doing
okay lat it man let me get to the hard
question right away how much can you
bench right now I'm down a little bit
now I hadn't been pressed in 20 years
probably come on
you look jacked well I don't I don't
know about that but getting comparison
to what well okay maybe are you in
better shape now than when you played I
think you know I mean people say that
when I see them I eat better than I did
my play I don't I don't
I made lifts once a week and it's just
you know just a routine you know not let
myself go left I do a lot of biking I do
a little running not not a lot of
running but it's so damn hot down here
in Mississippi it's uh it's hard to do
anything strenuous for any period of
time but you know I'm just trying to you
know trying to stay in good shape as I
can just not football shape my gosh I've
had enough you know people say you like
you go back playing I go look there's a
difference between you know looking like
you can play and actually physically
throwing the play if I got hit I just
fall apart I don't want to get get but
didn't done was there ever a point where
you didn't mind getting hit or you felt
like I hey once I get hit then then the
game starts you know as crazy as it
sounds
not for 19 years and going for that high
school in college I almost
IIIi don't want to say that I liked
being hit but I almost needed to be or
relished that aspect of the game like
the more you hit me the more it
motivated me if that makes sense and you
know I don't know if that's uh if that's
a good quality maybe while you're
playing it is you know now that I look
back I go maybe I should have been a
little more cautious and not not that I
look for hit but there were a lot of
times where I probably or or I shouldn't
say I probably but most people would
have said in my position would have said
I'm not playing next week I'm not
getting up from this hit and that would
have probably been the wiser choice but
you know at 25 or 30 I thought I knew it
all and and and I felt like what could
you not up go ahead then could you have
paced yourself different like looking
back now and having the perspective yeah
no you're right
yeah you could you know to answer your
question no it's easy to say it in
hindsight for any of us and it ain't any
you know any person looking back to you
know a different phase in their life
it's easier to you know to be critical
or or teach or coach or give advice or
whatever on your earlier self and and
that's what I'm doing right now but but
what I really you know being the person
that I am what I have been you know more
selective and and what I came back from
or how I played or no I don't I don't
think so you know again it's easier to
say it at 50 then it's once I went back
to being 25 I think I'd be bulletproof
again
do you care where you're ranked all-time
no I really don't you know at one time
it was a short time I could I could now
not that I did and I think for the
people who know me would would speak for
me if I ever mentioned what I had done
in a in a setting with other people
around in regards to accomplishments or
anything like that it was it was in a in
a way like for example I would say can
you believe that a guy who's whose dad
was his coach ran the wishbone offense
which the younger generation doesn't
even know what that that is and went to
got one offer in college played the
Southern Miss started all four years you
know in a really a run option style
offense can you believe that
that guy has every passing record good
and bad in the NFL who would have ever
thought and so I still I still can't
believe it
yeah you know records I never really had
you know when I was growing up I wanted
to play pro football what kid usually
doesn't I never thought about having NFL
records and and playing in Pro Bowls and
being inducted to the Hall of Fame I
just wanted to play and so I got a
chance to do that and on top of that I
got a chance to to accomplish so many
great things individually and as a team
how could I ever be you know upset that
my rankings are falling or my my records
have been broken for you know I I
pinched myself often but I can't believe
that I was able to do what I love to do
and do it for so long talking to Brett
Favre the Hall of Fame quarterback of
course you can hear him on Sirius XM
blitz every Tuesday at noon Eastern when
Patrick mahomes was coming out and the
scouts looked at him they said you know
Favre like and gunslinger it almost felt
like that was a negative like it almost
feels like gunslinger is undisciplined
but yeah right yeah yeah yeah yeah I can
see with you know that and I've had a
chance to Khorsandi and I go way back I
think the world of Andy I think you Dan
I mean you know Andy you know his
reputation is outstanding for for
grooming young quarterbacks and just
just guys playing for him every guy
that's ever play Fanny Reid I would say
there may be somebody out there who
thinks he's a bad coach or thinks he's a
bad guy but I don't know who that is but
but you know I had a chance to visit
about a month and a half ago I went up
and Peter King I did a little well we
spent a day with Patrick and Andy and
you know one of the things like I told
Patrick I said you know I see the
comparison in some respects I said but
the difference is and the same thing
with Baker Mayfield I've heard the
comparisons as well the difference is
they're more polished and what I mean by
that is they threw for more yards in
college and and we're in you know much
bigger games and settings and coming
from college to pro is not really a step
up as far as an offensive playbook
respective you know when I came out of
college I started all four years I threw
52 touchdowns at all all four years
combined dice know that in a season you
know easily in reading defenses and you
know just how you change protections and
all that stuff I didn't really get that
until my tenth year in the NFL and of
course the game changed and evolved for
that where nowadays it's it's
passing friendly league and you know one
of my coaches in college and I tell
people this all time I said what do we
do what do I do if they blitz and my
coach looked at me and he said you make
some happen that's what you do that was
that was the coaching advice and that
was right up my alley because I didn't
want to have to change the protection
you know based on what defense was
coming I didn't have that knowledge and
I ran the wishbone so what I could do
was make guys miss and buy some time in
swing one so it took me a long time to
kind of develop a somewhat of a
disciplined sense of playing the
position but these guys are coming in a
lot more now that can make plays with
defeat by time and I'll stop the stuff
but there's a lot more polished but I
wonder about that you bring up a great
point I never thought of that with you
that you know you grew up in a style in
in college where you know wasn't
predicated on like your read might have
been the defensive end whether you pitch
it or not now you're not and now you got
these kids who they're reading
everything that they're doing pro style
in high school you know they got their
iPad like all of that would you like
today's game would you have put in the
time studying that or was there still
part of you that said I like to almost
feel my way through a game no you know I
you know that's a great question man and
and what made you know I think the
people who who played with me especially
those who played with me over a period
of time and got to know me well and I
know the coaches that and I had a lot of
coaches either quarterback coaches OCS
and even head coaches I think they would
all say that it maybe this surprises
people maybe it doesn't but I was a
student of the game I really especially
as I got into my the second half of my
career you know I played in 20 years as
a long time so there's a lot of phases
throughout that 20 years but I really
wanted to
to be better mentally at the game and
and learn things that I had never been
exposed to you know coming when I left
high school I didn't even know what
shotgun was I mean it was reading and if
it was a pass it usually was a broken
play on a run play and the referees they
could tell the linemen if if the Lyman
downfield or four linemen were receivers
they didn't know so you know it was it
was just backyard football and and and
in college you're right I mean it was
reading the defense event and what
passes we threw were sprint out and
there was never any protection issues
but I wanted to I didn't do shotgun
until 2002 and so that was ten years
into my MI Pro mo pro career so when I
coached high school several years ago
everyone said I bet those kids had a
hard time adjusting to you and I said
totally the opposite
I kept the same offense that they had
run previous which was this no huddle
you know at the line of scrimmage deal
that was that was new to me and so I had
to I really had to I mean if we melt on
the ball then we knelt on it through
shotgun I could not believe it well but
it's a different it's a different game
it's a different era but I tried to soak
up in my later years as much as I could
and learn as much as I could you know I
just you know the ends like Tom Brady I
think he's a master at a lot of things
but for protection issues he makes it
look so easy and deciphering that and
you know I you know I I want to know
more about that and how how guys do it
how they were trained you know I just I
consider myself a student in the game
even though I was a hold on close a
gunslinger we just put up the picture of
you on draft day with your jean shorts
on by the way Baker Mayfield that was
classic man I mean the trouble he went
through to make that is
you know as lifelike or I mean it was
amazing I got a big chuckle out of that
I give a lot of credit
I just saw Hootie and the Blowfish on
tour and it brought me back didn't we
share a limo in Las Vegas with Hootie
animaux fish yeah we did yeah good guys
man I see Darius from time to time and I
mean time flies I remember you and your
son coming in I think it was right
before my last game or it was during my
last year it was your everything after
the Seattle game and we we thought you
were retiring
yeah which yeah which retirement yeah
but you were so angry we had launched in
the we had launched in the back yeah
your son a great kid he must have taken
after his mother yeah he's still a
Packer fan by the way
but yeah time sure flies man I remember
that as if it were yesterday
dude you're turning 50 50 can you
believe it in doing half three weeks
would you know it's hard to believe
would you thought you would you'd make
it to 50 if I said at 25 you're gonna
you're gonna be at negative 50 yes and
no the the yes part I mean is that is
that that side of me that thought I
would play forever and that the harder
you hit me the more I would you know dig
my heels in the nose side of me was the
side that eventually would quit drinking
and overcome pain pill addiction and it
would look at life a lot differently so
I'm very thankful that I've been able to
overcome a lot of obstacles in my way
and and that I'm I'm having this
conversation with you and about to turn
50 you should throw the ball 50 yards on
your 50th birthday you know I don't very
rarely do I throw a ball anymore you
know make surprised people you know they
may be
I think I go out in the backyard and
throw every day but hey when you have
those pickup games in the backyard all
the time don't you I used to oh okay
yeah can you throw it 50 oh I can easily
throw it 50 throw it 60 on your cell
value I can I can throw it 68 but I'm 50
there's no question now after that you
know it's a toss up your your arm is
going to be sore for days when you do
that well I wouldn't suppose it's funny
you say that
Liberty University I've never been there
was a great University I was really had
a great time just and one of the things
that they said at the end of your talk
are you up for throwing these neuro
footballs to the crowd and I said you
know absolutely my arm died and the next
day now I probably threw 10 balls but I
kind of joked with with Jerry Falwell Jr
I said now I'm gonna have to ice up
after the game after Poland in the next
day man I was like what did I do
so if I needed any help being reminded
that I'm about to turn 50 that was that
was a good reminder you should videotape
go out in the backyard and throw it
throw it 60 on your 50th but you know
loosen up a little bit though yes I was
never a loose enough type of guy of
course you weren't guys would stretch it
and I went right out on the field and
said what are you stretching for breathe
it doesn't matter
hey good luck with Sirius XM we
appreciate it don't be a stranger don't
you know wait till you're 60 to join us
again it's always great to catch up with
you I'm glad you're doing well
nice tan you too man that's Brett Favre
throughout the season you can hear him
every week Sirius XM NFL radio he hosts
the Sirius XM blitz every Tuesday
noon Eastern for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]